[Music]
this is star talks sports edition Neil
deGrasse Tyson you're a personal
astrophysicist and host today we're
discussing the topic of ice ice
every which way you would see it think
about it and find it on Earth and in the
heavens we're going to talk about why
ice is slippery I bet you've never
really thought about that one huh well
there's interesting surface physics
related to it we're going to talk about
ice in sports not all sports use ice in
the same way as one another so that's a
whole other Frontier of winter sports
and we're going to talk about glaciers
uh how what are they how they move and
why and what they do to Earth's surface
all on this episode of Star talk sports
edition and introduce my co-host Chuck
Nice Jack hey Neil now are we going to
talk about
Vanilla Ice Ice
Cube iced tea okay we will save that for
the third segment I promise okay okay
all right all right
Chuck is a stand-up comedian an actor
and also game show host for brain games
which is streaming on the National
Geographic uh Network I guess you find
that buried within Disney I also got uh
Gary Riley Gary how you doing I'm good
I'm good as we record this the World Cup
is still being contested played and you
took time away from that to do a show on
ice so Gary I love you man I love you I
know it's hard I love you too no no no
it's fine it's uh this show needs to be
made and the guys are gonna have to do
it without me
the guys at the pub are gonna have to
watch the shows without the players
they're going to have to play a great
game without me watching so it's just
they're responsibility
Gary's uh
alone ex professional Sportsman here as
a former footballer in the UK so Gary
what what show have you and your
producers assembled today for ice it's
been coming and going for ages ice and
right now I guess everyone knows it's
packed its bags and it's heading for the
ocean
um and we'll get to that I'm sure later
humankind has learned to live with it
use it try to understand it and even try
and have fun with it and I can't think
of anyone better to ride a Zamboni with
than our guest uh Lori winkless if you
don't remember I'll explain if you do
then you'll know you're in for a treat
Lori is a physicist an astrophysicist an
author a science communicator and
storyteller
she's a science journalist and lecturer
and her books include science in the
city and sticky the secret science of
surfaces so Neil Lori winkless is back
we got and that must have been the most
beautiful thing anyone has ever said to
anyone will you ride the Zamboni with me
that's would you agree with that I'm so
flattered I would do anything Gary to
have that opportunity I've never been
honest it just seemed it just seemed
like the best thing to to you know what
what can we use on On Ice
I'm in I'm in can't be angry all right
we'll try to make that happen so Lori I
just want to lead off by asking what
makes ice
slippery do people say well because it
gets wet and you slip on the wet ice but
on an ice skating rink the ice is you
know if it's been skated on it's kind of
Frosty right from everybody uh kicking
up a top layer of
shaved ice but that's slippery too and
no matter what I'm wearing so you see
people at the end of a hockey game the
coach comes out he's got to step lightly
on the ice lest he slip so just
wondering what's going on there and does
it have anything to do with the sketchy
character of ice
it's very sketchy in its character yeah
exactly and I honestly that is true and
that's true scientifically to Chuck
because ice is not always slippery if
you get ice cold enough
the friction that it generates is really
high so it actually becomes a very
grippy surface so if you're way down at
like minus 100 degrees C the friction
that a skate or a shoe that would
experience on that ice is extremely high
it's as if you're walking on a very
rough surface but as the temperature of
ice increases and kind of heads towards
its melting temperature so I'm sorry I'm
speaking in centigrade but I'm useless
of Fahrenheit and we'll forgive you okay
thank you so yeah it starts very high
friction and then the friction actually
gradually decreases and it reaches a
minimum at about minus seven degrees C
and that's quite a useful temperature
because that's the type of temperature
that we would quite often interact with
on an ice skating rink and although
there have been theories around what how
that happens why friction decreases
gradually over that range it wasn't
really until about 2018 that researchers
I think probably got closest to kind of
nailing down the answer to why and it's
that there is always a presence of what
they call a quasi-liquid there's always
this ultra thin like just a few
nanometers thin layer of quasi-liquids
which Daniel Bond the scientist who
wrote this paper in 2018 would not let
me call a liquid a quasi-liquid and that
exists on Ice even at temperatures well
below freezing so ice always has this
layer on there and and that contributes
to its slipperiness just to be clear a
nanometer is a billionth of a meter so
you yeah uh you know we hear the word
Nano so often that it's almost lost its
Precision Nanobots Nano this Nano and
but you're using the word within its
precise metric uh prefix way
um nanometers billionths of a meter thin
just to clarify that yeah quasi-liquid I
mean uh that's that's rather vague and
amorphousous
liquid I mean come on really yeah well
yeah this is that I I had this argument
with the scientists as well but his his
argument and it's a reasonable one is
that if it's below freezing it should be
a solid so we shouldn't be calling it a
liquid right but what it actually is is
that on the surface of ice you have
little ice molecules water molecules
that are bound to all the other water
molecules around us and and normally ice
is bonded to four neighbors right on the
surface of ice it's bonded to three or
four because it's on the surface there's
air above it it's no longer surrounded
by more ice
um but what these guys realized and
actually I should say their brothers the
two lead scientists on on this paper
one's a chemist one's a physicist that's
problematic right there indeed indeed
hence the quasi-liquid argument I
believe
oh yes will be what they realized is
that on the surface of ice at these
temperatures at this kind of minus seven
degrees C it's not just three or four
bonds it's sometimes ice is only bonded
to two neighbors and those doubly bonded
ice molecules they don't just kind of
Wiggle around on the surface which is
what creates this this quasi-liquid
layer they can actually roll around the
surface of the ice they're very very
mobile and it's actually those hardly
bonded to their neighbors molecules of
ice that cause that creates this this
liquidy liquidy layer that creates that
slipperiness so so you know what we you
know what we call that in in in just the
regular world this kind of semi-formed
liquid that you're talking about we call
it gel gel
so Laurie the bond brothers are doing
their research in 2018 right and they
have all of the technology to do it but
back in the day way back in the day
Michael in about 1850 was coming up with
terms like regeneration am I right and
but although molecules the kind of the
theory back then wasn't popular about
molecular and atoms all the rest of it
but he was already on it
he totally was yeah Michael Faraday had
this idea that there was some sort of
liquid layer on the surface of ice and
that if you brought two ice cubes
together those liquid layers would
interact and it would allow the ice
cubes to to kind of freeze together so
that's the process of Regulation but
because like you said Gary because this
theory of atoms that didn't exist yet it
was kind of ignored Faraday was kind of
like yeah okay you're a great scientist
etc etc but that doesn't seem to make
sense to us and it was kind of Revisited
again another 100 years later by a
different scientist and that was where
you know we then had the theory of atoms
and molecules so that started to really
kind of open the floodgates as it were
to this theory that there's some sort of
permanent liquidy layer on the surface
of ice I think just just to be more
precise here I think we had a theory of
atoms but atoms were not yet
demonstrated to exist
so because we had the periodic table of
elements you know an element be an atom
in its smallest form so we had some
suspicions that atoms mattered but not
in what way and quantum physics was was
a distant dream not even a dream so yeah
I just want to distinguish between what
we thought might have been true and what
would later be confirmed that's all God
does
[Laughter]
[Music]
is there a difference between the ice
that forms here on Earth and Ice that
goes and forms in deep space on comets
and moons and things
that's a good question I mean I can only
answer a tiny bit of it but I'm sure
Neil can answer way more than this yeah
but wait a minute before you answered
that yeah doesn't that change based on
what the ice is because when we talk ice
we're talking water but in space you got
to have different kinds of ice other
than water right yeah good points but
yeah even even water ice forms
differently on different planets as far
as I understand delicious water ice
water ice but yeah it's it's crystalline
ices is the most common form of lights
on Earth but my understanding is that
amorphous ice so not ice that forms
these lovely crystals but ice that's
more kind of uniform that is what
dominates in the rest of our solar
system um but I'm sure Neil will correct
me if I'm wrong oh man and this is good
stuff now let's get into this
what's up with the iceberg no it's a new
wrapper amorphous ice you see he's
that's when it's got to be made
and this is is it more for ice slippery
so yeah there's a there's amorphosize
had character traits like slippery oh
yeah yeah new superhero but wait so so
I'm just astonished here Lori that here
it is
we're going to the year 2023 and you're
telling me that a research paper
five years ago is still shedding light
on our understanding of the surface of
ice
I think when I started to research slice
I thought we know all this right we know
it all right Lori Lori one of your
expertise is material physics right so
should you be embarrassed by this that
your field didn't even know this until
you know just before covid you know
there's so many questions to answer and
only so much is available
there's too many surfaces too little
time okay two little too little money
too little time yeah if the ice is
different in deep space as opposed to
here on Earth
would it be as Chuck said
from different molecules not water
molecules but other properties yeah
we've got ammonia ice there are other
things that are there's carbon dioxide
ice
which on Earth we call Laurie
dry ice dry ice yeah yes
don't stick your tongue to that by the
way do not Chuck speaking from
experience it sounds like
you know believe me this thing I'm
talking to you with is a prosthetic your
tongue exactly
I'm so so a couple more things so it
seems to me be interesting if you had a
a race
let's say you know a quarter
you know the two a 400 meter race or or
a kilometer where the beginning of the
race the surf the whole race has run on
ice
but at the beginning it's like a hundred
below so you get very high friction and
so they're just running and running but
the the track gets warmer and warmer
until the finish line
and then there's a some point where it's
no longer High friction it's low
friction so they have to run differently
and then the last 50 hours they just
slide in
it's a pretty cool event uh it is also
the most expensive ice rink in the world
it started a year okay hey it does take
them a long time to make ice for the
Winter Olympics so yeah I don't know if
they could do that gradient maybe maybe
they could so Lori tell me about the
attachment to other molecules when I
think of a a crystal I think you have a
molecule in its place and the Crystal
has certain symmetry to it so I'd be
looking different directions and I'd
find neighbor molecules attached to me
yeah in crystalline form but you tell me
as you get to the surface I'm missing
one or more of these and on some level
it can actually roll around if I'm
attached at all how am I rolling around
yeah it's a good question and the answer
is not that straightforward because they
had to model these they had to model
these doubly bonded molecules so they
haven't seen them they haven't actually
seen what they look like but what they
found was that as the temperature
increased towards -7 degrees C the
mobility of these molecules in their
model increased so as it was as if they
were rolling around on the surface now
we haven't seen that so we haven't seen
it experimentally it is it is a model
result but it does match very nicely
with the with the decreasing friction
that we see okay so that's the
vocabulary they have available to them
to reference it that way yeah but it's
interesting so if a molecule only
rotated a little bit you know moved
around a little bit and then the next
one picks it up and the next one picks
it up you know the molecule wouldn't
have to move very far to still give the
impression of a very slippery surface it
seems to me yes precisely that and I
think it's what was really surprising to
them was was just how different the
mobility these movement of these
molecules just how different it was
between three bonds and two bonds they
really were not expecting that it was
significantly more mobile so Laurie do
we are we now consigned
pressure melting to the bin
to the trash can to the bins
pressure melting that's my only
understanding of any of this now you're
going to put it in a trash bin
yeah no no I'm asking um
yes it's got to be yeah what's the
temperature
um so thank you it's um it's that
situation where yes pressure melting
must still happen but it's not the
reason when you put your foot directly
onto ice that you slip because you've
got no there's no pressure really
happening there there's not high
pressure of an ice of an ice skate yes a
blade yeah totally so are we consigning
that theory to nah and it's more this
unstable group of molecules that will
and will not float around the surface of
ice
um pressure melting does Place some sort
of a limited role and it actually plays
a role in one of the winter sports like
curling oh let's get we're going to get
to that we're going to get to that but
you gotta explain pressure melting we're
gonna save that for the second second
what is pressure melting
all right when we come back Lori tells
us how you get pressure melting with ice
on StarTalk sports edition
we're back StarTalk sports edition
we've got our favorite ice expert in the
whole world Lori Winkles coming to us
from where are you where are you right
now
I'm in Wellington in New Zealand where
it is summer okay sorry yeah it's summer
and winter here that's evidence that the
distance of Earth from the sun is not
what causes seasons if you would ever
wondered that it's just how we're tilted
either tore the Sun or away so Lori take
tell us what pressure melting is I think
it's one of the most interesting
phenomenon involving water and it's not
other materials I think water is almost
unique in this property and then we want
to find out how that relates to all the
sports that people know and love that
take place on the ice yeah pressure
melting you're right Neil water is a
very weird molecule in some ways and so
pressure mounting is what happens that
when when you apply pressure to solid
ice what you actually do is you push the
atoms in that ice closer together now
you think about that as as making it
denser but because water is denser than
ice
when ice is under pressure it turns into
some of us turns into liquid water
so it's even though the temperature is
below freezing
even though the temperature is below
freezing right right so you will have
you would have created water in a liquid
state that is stable below the freezing
temperature because you put pressure on
it
yes and if you remove the Press
right so it does need the continuous
Supply application of pressure to to
keep that layer of water but that that
weird quasi liquid that we talked about
that exists regardless of whether
there's pressure on the ice or not so is
that why when you have
um a container uh in the freezer
and before the container bursts
you the it's complete liquid but then
you twist the top
and the whole thing goes and freezes up
all at once
yeah that's another that's a thing
called nucleation and it's what happens
when if you have the the liquid can stay
can stay liquids excuse me the water can
stay liquid below freezing but the act
of kind of hissing it or you know
banging it in some way causes some of
the water molecules because they're cold
to line up in a line and then what you
see is that ice just going and if it
forms out into the liquid so don't you
need very water for that
don't you need very no you can actually
do it no it doesn't need to be that pure
you can actually do it with kind of you
know pretty decent bottled water or if
you have filtered water if you're very
careful and you put it into your freezer
and leave it there for a few hours and
very carefully take it out and then give
it a smack on on the countertop you can
quite often see the ice forming yeah
it's pretty cool experiment it's very
cool watch ice form right in front of
your eyes it's very it's very cool Lori
the bond brothers and the their research
in 2018 right came up with that minus
seven
specific temperature
yet you can't tell me that for centuries
icemeisters as they're known I believe
weren't already well ahead of them
because we've been such a nice Meister
so someone okay Chuck um an ice Master
is is someone who lays the ice they will
construct a skating rink uh Escape Track
a curling ice whatever it is because
they're all different types of ice
figure skating ice is not the same as
ice you play ice hockey on it has to
have different qualities now the ice
meister's knew this so why didn't the
bomb Brothers just go and speak to an
icemeister
well I think they they did but I think
the other thing is you know there's
there's knowing through kind of
experimentation and then there's
understanding from a fundamental point
of view and you're absolutely right Gary
icemeisters have known about the the
changing behavior of ice at different
temperatures for a very very long time
and it is the basis of all winter sports
really but it's only really now that we
start to understand the very fundamental
mechanism that reflects that observation
so it's you need both I think but yeah
for sure and and the ice Masters I spoke
to have such an incredible Instinct of
understanding of ice like some of them
described being able to listen to the
ice to know where the ice Whisperers
but Gary this this is a very common arc
of Discovery and understanding in
science where people just observing
people notice something
and then they like write it down or or
share the information and it's they
might even exploit it in whatever way
they need and then science comes later
typically and figures out what's
actually going on and then when you do
that you can usually exploit it even
further right so so Lori in the era of
modern science have they improved on
what the ice meisters had been doing I
think see something they could or should
yeah in terms of their understanding yes
um but the ice mice just still do what
they do as they've always done what
helped them a bit is the ability to
purify water so for ice makers they
really do want very very pure water
because they want to know exactly how
the ice will form with as few kind of
dirty bits in there as possible or any
other contaminants so that has science
has helped them hugely in that regard
because you now have technologies that
allow you to filter the water but they
still very much see it as a kind of an
instinctive art really and curling eyes
particularly because it's different from
the other ice like they are artists
those ice makers they they have
they've tried different machines to
create curling ice but nothing has
managed to create it as uniformly as a
human walking up and down the ice with
effectively a shower head and that's
because the machines can't listen to us
exactly
Larry before we get on to curling and I
do want to get onto curling because it's
a fascinating sport for physics and I
mean it's it's how many hundreds Gary
said it's a fascinating sport for
physicists
no in terms of it's fascinating and it's
hundreds of years old and we still don't
know all of its secrets but before we go
there please explain the impemba effect
that I believe right yes thank you
suggests that hot water can freeze
faster than cold water because now I I
need some illumination no
I don't believe that for a minute
do it wait Chuck Lori here's what I
think happens there because I've seen
people do this experiment here's what I
think happens they put boiling water in
an ice tray and cold water in an ice
tray then they put them both into the
freezer and then the boiling water that
ice tray freezes faster what I think
happened there it was is that it
evaporated water out and there was less
water to freeze by the end is that not
what happened there
no I think that's my understanding of it
as well like there's been lots of papers
and lots of uh you know observations of
this over the years but yeah I'm I'm
kind of with you on the on that Neil I
think that's what happened yeah in the
end it's less water to freeze and so it
freezes faster exactly so it happens
quicker yeah yeah all right that makes
perfect sense because otherwise it would
have to be some manipulation of
temperature like where you don't have
the same rate of freezing yeah because I
don't care what you do you got to go
from hot to cold yeah you've got to pass
through the temperature that the other
Ice Cube was it wasn't in the fast lane
so with the way to do that experiment
properly is you put boiling water in a
vessel that's sealed and cold water so
that's that way nobody can evaporate out
and then it's pure temperature race
that's why it's just a bit bushy this
one I thought I'd tell you that all
right I had my answer okay okay so Lori
so I'm I'm at a loss why is the ice for
curling different than for hockey
different than for figure skating so
figure skating iced and hockey ice and
long like
smooth ice now they're different from
each other they're at different
temperatures they have different
thicknesses etc etc
um because each of those Sports want to
do something different right like long
track speed skating is all about going
as fast as you can like 50 kilometers an
hour with your legs on the ice and so
there you want really hard really low
friction ice so it's asked the magic
temperature of minus seven degrees C and
then it gets warmer from there but
curling ice is not smooth ice so curling
ice they do make a flat rink a flat
surface of ice first and then one of
these ice meisters will walk up and down
the whole length of the curling rink and
they will use basically a shower head
which had they've got a bucket of water
on their back and they spray they swing
a shower head from side to side
different little nozzle sizes on the
shower head and it creates a layer of
Pebbles they call them Pebbles but ice
bumps all over the surface so if you
look at a curling ice rink it's it's
quite dull it's not not smooth and shiny
like a speed skating rink and that's
because it has this deliberately why
aren't they trying to reduce the
friction
so what they're trying to do really is
if you try and curl a curling Stone so
if you try and make a curling Stone take
that big curvy path on smooth ice it
will not do that oh you need the
friction to change directions
so in the thing Neil the thing is don't
don't forget the origin of curling it's
on a frozen pond or a frozen lake and
therefore Mother Nature just organically
produces this pebbling these ice bumps
nothing bumpier than a than a than a
frozen lake surface tell you that yeah
well yeah so they they have kind of if
Dew forms on an ice surface you will get
these bumps so yeah it's and like Gary
said it's been around curling as a
sports being around for at least 500
years and started in Scotland and has
kind of gone everywhere that Scottish
settlers have so it's it's kind of
relatively big it's not really but it's
relatively big in New Zealand as well
where we had a lot of Scottish settlers
down the bottom of the South Island all
right that makes a lot of sense now the
whole thing makes sense to me now why
there's no curling in Africa
I mean yeah because there's not not
because of the ice just because of the
sky
it's delightful the teams even like the
teams I met some teams who play here and
they all have like these these kind of
woolly hats with the Bobble on them like
very kind of traditional Scottish uh
Garb that they still wear and they have
tartans and stuff for each of the teams
so it's still very much seen as a
Scottish sport so the Scots are actually
responsible for two of the world's most
boring Sports golf
I agree on golf I love curling though no
I love curling so so Laurie there's
there's been a little bit of a
uh an argument a spat a tiff call it
what you like
um pressure warming Theory and then
scratch guiding Theory and then there's
the pivot slide model two yeah as to
which one is the most in the most
explanatory for why a curling Stone does
what it does but before we get to that
would you explain actually what the
bottom is of a curling stone is like
because I think people yeah people might
have no idea of it and not quite there
you go so this is for you
okay so the reason that there are so
many theories about curling is that a
curling Stone moves in a way that you
wouldn't expect if you were just looking
at really basic physics right so the
base of a curling stone is not flat it's
actually concave so there's only a very
narrow ring and these stones are
granished they're made from a really
particular Granite from one place in
Scotland
um and it's this really narrow band of
granite that actually touches the ice
and then as we've established the ice
itself is pebbled so it's kind of rough
so it's really only touching the tops of
these Pebbles right so you have the
slightly odd interaction anyway you've
got a rough Granite surface and a rough
textured ice and if you were to say take
like a beer bottle I recommend it being
empty before you do this and slide it
along a table and you know it will just
slide forward if you slide it and rotate
it as you release it which is what a
curler will do before they release a
curling Stone
the the beer bottle will Veer away from
that straight line it'll kind of go off
to the right or the left depending on
which direction you've rotated it okay
so if you rotate a beer bottle to the
right as you let it go it will curl to
the left
and this is called asymmetric friction
so that's kind of something that we kind
of know in the world of physics it's
because of the way the bottle
decelerates as it moves forward and
friction is stronger on the front than
on the back of the bottle it's not
surprising so this is how a beer bottle
will move right but if so you have you
curl to the rice and it will sorry you
rotate to the right it'll curl to the
left a curling Stone will curl in the
same direction in which it rotates
so from a physics point of view that is
weird right if it was following this
basic like asymmetric friction it would
curl in the opposite direction to the
one that it spins
so that's why people have been like what
is going on with this weird Sport and
again like Gary said earlier there's a
case of people understand instinctively
how to rotate a stone how to deliver a
curling Stone they understand all of
this they understand what happens when
they move a stone the way they do but
the fundamental understanding of what's
Happening where that kind of rough
Granite surface is touching the rough uh
paddled ice it is still a little bit up
for debase now I'd argue that there's
probably a couple of uh leading theories
but probably one leading theory at the
moment but I just love that it's still
up for today's given that this is the
sport that's been around for centuries
well I will tell you this uh Lori what
you have done is given the world a way
to make curling uh infinitely more
interesting
that is put a beer bottle on top of the
curling Stone
and
have it delivered to the people at the
end of the run all right so Lori
typically a hockey
is the same season as the Ice capades uh
the literal ice capades or whatever is
that version today that we all grew up
with going to Arenas and are you
suggesting that when they do their
figure skating in the ice capades they
might change the temperature of the ice
to serve their needs relative to the
hockey game that's going to play that
evening
yeah they will do so um you you for
figure skating what you want is a kind
of a softer ice to be honest because if
you think about what a figure skater is
doing they're having to kind of dig into
the ice so that they can launch upwards
so they actually need to get the blades
into the ice so they need the stats of
the Winter Olympic Games figure skating
is the softest warmest ice it's um like
minus five degrees C I'm sorry minus
three degrees C is figure skating
um but ice hockey needs something a bit
harder because they have to they need
that combination of grip and glide you
know they're changing direction a lot so
ice hockey ice tends to be about minus
five degrees C so you can switch between
the two and you tend to need to flood
you tend to go I think from memory I
think you go ice hockey to figure
skating I think that's right
um but you can kind of add more water
you flood the ice they literally flood
it with water and let it freeze and then
add more water and let it freeze and
they can change the under lying
temperature of the what's underneath the
compressors and stuff underneath so they
they do you know in an Ideal World and
in a competition they would absolutely
want to change temperatures and so but
isn't that laying a layer of water is
not what the Zamboni does right yeah
yeah it is yeah right yeah yeah yeah so
do we do we need to consider these
brushes that curlers use and we didn't
didn't we go through a phase where they
had something known as the Franken broom
yes broom Gates
oh yeah gotta have got to have one of
those
let me guess the the broom actually
um was more abrasive and scratched the
ice to create more pebble-like surface
so that the curl could increase
yeah so the broom
Chuck it's pretty much bang on yeah
holding out on us Chuck you you you're a
total curling fan you probably Chuck's
written axles Chuck's red Lori's book
no you're right the brooms um that would
they use now are pretty like a nylon
they're not abrasive and the the job of
the sweeper the people who are sweeping
the brooms in front of the curling Stone
they are actually trying to melt the ice
so what they are trying to do is reduce
how much the curling Stone curls so they
want to straighten out the path of the
curling Stone so they sweep furiously
create this little liquid layer and that
kind of minimizes how much the curling
Stone so they're using friction that's
where they rub it real fast to get
friction out of that they rub it real
fast yeah exactly we got to take a break
when we come back we'll finish out the
curling controversy here we're going to
learn whether Chuck really did write a
book on curling and performs in the dark
of night and we're gonna find out ice on
Earth what's it all about with glaciers
when Star talk sports edition all about
we're back StarTalk sports edition with
our number one ice expert Lori winkliffs
Lori coming to us from New Zealand
thanks for coming in this far for this
episode Lori so I got some some leftover
questions for you what I wonder is
I if we move this whole exercise to
Earth's surface
all right and we get things like snow on
the sides of mountains
skiers care greatly about what the
texture of the snow is could you briefly
just tell me what they prefer and do
they prefer it because they have more
friction or because they have less
friction so I don't ski but like a good
scientist I talk to people who's gay
um and they prefer natural snow but
something we saw in and we are
increasingly seeing in the Winter
Olympics is a kind of a Reliance on
manufactured snow because we aren't
getting enough snow in these regions to
actually host the Olympic Games so
skiers definitely prefer the the the
softer natural snow mostly because it is
softer
um the manufactured snow is when you
look at it under a microscope it's kind
of solid little icy balls more like than
snowflakes and so it's harder and it's
slippery why can't we make snowflakes
it's the 21st century yeah we've I don't
know if anyone's tried if I'm honest we
did have a couple of guys remember that
they made artificial snow but they
couldn't they couldn't scale it oh I
remember that we have a whole episode on
that okay that we did yeah right now or
after the show everybody go to the
archives and dig out we have a whole
episode Gary I forgot all about that
they had perfected it yeah and the
question was did they make enough of it
useful on an entire Mountainside is what
that was but okay so picking that up and
we need to check back with those guys
because if they've conquered that scale
issue uh that's an investment
opportunity
all right so so Lori so let me hand you
some low-hanging fruit you ready so what
happens if it snows
and the snow never goes away
as in formation of a place
all right so it's so funny see this is
these are tricks to see people you just
found out what a trick question is to a
scientist would you ask a question that
is so simple they're like what the hell
is happening
a small amount of panic just rising up
in my in my chest so what's the
difference between the era of the growth
of glaciers and the era of the loss of
glaciers like what's what's going on why
why does it happen one way at one time
and the other way the other time
and that's
a stick but
a lot of our freshwater systems
especially in mountainous areas they
actually rely on glaciers to get fresh
water so when they have less snow
because of climate change the Glaciers
are melting or and or not forming so
both of those and their fresh water
supplies are are in are you know damaged
by that so climate change is is the
answer unfortunately exactly and while
you're on that subject just let me just
say this because people may be thinking
so what glaciers don't affect me however
drinking water does affect you so no
matter where you are most likely a lot
of your uh places your drinking water
comes from elevation it comes from
mountainous areas where we get what's
called a snowpack that snow pack slowly
melts uh in the spring and feeds TR uh
you know arteries that feed tributaries
and that brings you your fresh drinking
water when we don't have the snow
because of warmer temperatures we don't
have the drinking water and that
actually leads to a depletion of
aquifers and it also leads to Drought so
this is why one of the reasons why
climate change is so terribly important
because
um you like drinking water this public
service announcement brought to you by
start talking I mean Chuck Chuck's
absolutely spot on and don't and add to
that Chuck immigration for crops and for
farming
you missed something in that that PSA
that PSA was beautiful let me just start
out by that but it's not whether or not
it's cold enough to snow
the point okay because if it rains
that'll also fill the aquifer right so
what the snow does is it allows the
water accumulation of the winter to
return to you in times when it melts
so exactly and replenish the aquifer in
the spring or whenever the rotation of
Seasons uh brings it so so what the
problem is you don't have the storage of
water as that glaciers had provided and
ever since the ice age that is really
the key that is the key is point to it
that I did that I did kind of gloss over
is is that the snow itself is the
storage of the water yes yes yes which
is fan which is Nature's incredible
mechanism because when it rains people
say so what so it rains rain is then run
off so think of it that right right
yeah and at the bottom of the inflation
there's a river coming out the bottom
right so yeah but is it right is it
always a river is is it not that cold it
actually freezes to the the Bedrock it
depends it depends on the glacier to be
honest like the glaciologists who I've
interviewed over the last while have
said that no two Glaciers are the same
you know so some some parts of a glacier
will stick to the Bedrock uh whereas you
might also get these kind of streams
like Neil mentioned that form underneath
the glacier too so you have a
combination of kind of sticking ice and
slippery water and you also the weight
of the glacier
it's kind of as if it's on a hill lived
in a mountainous area it's kind of
constantly moving forward because of
internal deformation so you have all of
these forces acting together to to cause
the movement of Glacier wait wait so the
ice I'm making in my freezer isn't
rolling out of the freezer come on the
floor so is why would froze Why Would
frozen water or or packed ice move at
all I mean who why I'm just sitting
there I don't care if it's on a hill
it's frozen there
yeah why is it gonna flow I don't get it
so you have a combination of sliding at
the base like we mentioned so you have
some ice that's sticking on the surface
um and you will have this formation
probably due to kind of pressure melting
type activities and where you have these
streams of of liquid water that
lubricate the movement but you also just
have if you think about ice it's not a
it's not an eternally solid material
right it is there's always slight
movement and this is true for most
materials on a long enough time scale a
lot of things flow even things that we
think of as solid and I these Glaciers
are massive they are absolutely enormous
and that waist the weight of the ice
combined with it being you know on a
slope will mean that the front part of
it is moving ever so slightly more and
the internally you have this constant
kind of movement of ice molecules within
the glacier what's the difference
between ice
and compacted snow because a glacier is
compacted snow so what's the difference
yeah
yeah very very good point so
wait a glacier forms is you have the
have the snow it
defies over time you get these the ice
molecules the water molecules get
Tighter and Tighter and Tighter together
and in that process air gets squeezed
out so you start to lose the kind of
white fluffiness aspect of snow which
has lots and lots of air involved in it
and it starts to turn into something
that looks a lot more like ice so it's
much much denser so the ice the
snowflakes effectively lose their
structure and and they turn into this
kind of granular ice surface and that at
the first stage of that I think is
called Fern so it's a particular type of
ice that has been created from snowfall
and then after Decades of this kind of
cycle of you know snowfall melting
compaction all of that stuff you will
actually get types you will get ice deep
in a glacier and you may have seen this
in images that looks blue it has so
little air in there that it's almost
completely transparent and and that so
that's one of the glaciologists I talked
to she described Glacier Ice as a type
of metamorphic rock
because it is formed so specifically on
this geological scale over long periods
of time just like other metamorphic
rocks you still didn't say why it's blue
okay so I know because it's sad it's
very very sad I didn't ask you Chuck
oh my understanding of us which could be
wrong right my understanding of it is
it's the way that light is scattered
through large Columns of of solid water
in this kind of similar way to the
oceans looking blue to us the tail light
scatters
yeah okay so Laurie do we do we look at
glaciers as kind of like you've talked
about them being like meta
metamorphic rock are they not like a
little bit more like plastic with the
deformation and oh I like that yeah
they'll crevasse and then they'll then
they'll start to move they'll be a
there'll be a free yeah okay yes that's
a that's a great observation Gary it is
especially deep down in the glacier
where you know the deformation is kind
of constant whereas you know on the
surface of glaciers you'll sometimes see
these big crevasses and that's because
the the ice or snow at that level is is
a lot more brittle but down in the in
the base of the glacier it's much more
like a plastic than anything else and
you need those crevasses so we can dig
out the dead cavemen okay who fell in
looking for food it was Louie he'd come
back since for a week all right let's
keep going
no this is true right it's some of our
best DNA are the retreat of glaciers and
we've got prehistoric creatures
including humans coming out of it yeah
because there's no air and you know
they're so it's so condensed that it is
actually quite good at preserving stuff
yeah that's that's why they find woolly
mammoths in in the apartment yeah yeah
and what yeah Lori let's go back to what
Neil's point about those ice streams
that are yeah very rapid and come
through on the base of glaciers now do
we not have something recently where
there was what they called an underwater
tsunami created by one of these or a
whole load of these ice streams that
come through out of the ice sheet
yeah that does sound familiar I'm I'm
not I don't think I know enough about
that in particular to mention it but I
do I do remember seeing something
um a few years ago now and it was there
was a particular Glacier I'm gonna say
Greenland I apologize if that's wrong
um but it was moving it was found to be
moving like something like 40 meters a
day
um which was is much faster than it
really should be moving yeah that's no
longer a glacial pain it's an ice
tsunami right that you can but you can
run away from that one
that's true yeah so the thing is
everybody everybody looks at glaciers
and rising sea levels and they see the
face of a glacier or the ice sheet just
collapse into the ocean yeah this is now
the double whammy of ice streams coming
through and the collapse
yeah of an ice sheet it is it's speeding
up this water lubricates the flow of the
glacier right yeah it really does yeah
right and not only that it uh weakens
the structure beneath so that it's
collapsing so think of it as like when
you're making a if you have a little a
tunnel but then the water itself is the
drill that made the tunnel and you have
more water coming through the tunnel so
it's it's a runaway
yeah yeah and if it's moving then it's
not going to be it's not going to freeze
as well right and you and you need
refreeze as as a part of the process
which uh you know listen this is serious
stuff uh we're screwed people
I must ask you this Lori when it's cold
enough
for water to freeze or a frost to occur
it doesn't always
and there must be some reasons as to why
if it's minus something if there's no
Frost is it what is it air pressure is
it what is it it's a it's a combination
of different things like you do you do
need cold temperatures that's kind of
obvious I suppose like you said but you
also need things like
um nucleation points so something for uh
water molecule to cling on to for long
enough
um to form a crystal you know to form an
ice a molecule you do need that as well
um and you temperature wise there's also
this thing called the Dew temperature
and so you and and that in in most
aspects of normal life the Dew
temperature the dew points I should say
and the freezing point are are pretty
similar
um but you do also need that that
nucleation point so like Chuck mentioned
earlier you can have liquid water at
temperatures well below freezing if you
don't have something for for those water
molecules to cling onto to become Ice by
the way I would add to that that there's
more than in one source of thermal
energy reaching the surface of a pond if
you want to call it if let's say we're
thinking of a puddle right well the
puddle freeze over overnight and so you
have whatever retained
temperature the ground is
from having heated during the day so
even if the air above it drops below
freezing the pond might delay against
that because it's got heat from the
ground but also there are layers of the
atmosphere that if there's a pocket of
warmth it can radiate to the puddle and
that's a second source of energy that
could prevent it from freezing at a
freezing point so I'm saying it's
there's more thermal physics going on
and only when all the rest of that gets
gets used up all that other heat sources
get used up then the air temperature
will will win for sure but Lori give us
some parting thoughts here what should
we think about going forward and I'm
afraid to go to Chuck because it'll give
us another Public Service Announcement
and we don't have time for that so
how about you the future of ice research
Lori what's what can we look forward to
well what I'm kind of hoping to see is
some interesting work around can we
Design Surfaces so that they you know
change how ice forms on them you know
maybe maybe we could not that we want to
seed glaciers necessarily but if we
could Design Surfaces that would allow
ice to form very efficiently that could
be interesting for lots of reasons the
other end of that scale is there are
lots of Industries who don't want ice to
form on surfaces like the aviation
sector right you don't want ice forming
on your plane and so this that's kind of
the other end of the same question so I
definitely like to see more around that
space and whether it's scalable or not I
have I have no real sense I think
probably not at this point Lori where do
we find you on social media
um I'm on Twitter um Lori underscore
Winkles and I'm a mastodon as well with
the same handle wow Master Don okay and
and your most recent book um my most
recent book is sticky and there's a
whole chapter on Ice in there and lots
of curling controversies as well oh
there it is
sticky love that title all right we got
to call it quits there uh Lori Delight
to have you back on Star Talk and this
truly won't be our last invitation to
you uh the Winter Olympics is is surely
just around the corner and no better
time to get you back on than that Chuck
Garing always good to have you there man
all right Neil deGrasse Tyson here your
personal astrophysicist as always keep
looking up
foreign